[Musik]
so Sandy wir gehen rauf auf den Server
ne lass mich das mal kurz hier erstmal
öffnen
gehen ne
ich bin jetzt da
[Musik]
oh nein
ich Park mal kurz hier unser Boot Steig
mal aus wie steigt man mit W
mit Doppelklick
Luca ich fahre irgendwie weiter
[Musik]
dürfen wir hier die Tür Schlachten ist
ja nicht unser Dorf
[Musik]
du bist ja schon Trottel du sollst
einsteigenbaum siehst sag Bescheid ne ja
ich weiß nicht mal wie es aussieht aber
okay
peinlich hast noch keins also beschwer
dich nicht ja das ist ja das Ziel für
heute ich baue jetzt eins ich habe eine
Idee für ein Haus aber ich brauche halt
Fichten
ja das liegt nur daran weil du mir da
irgendwie was komisches aufgebaut hast
nach vorne mein Piratenschiff außer dem
liegt Schönheit in Betracht des Menschen
im Auge des Betrachters heißt
viele meinen ja schon ich soll so ein
Treehouse bauen auch sehr sehr cool die
Sache ist allerdings dass ich Fichten
benötige was haltet ihr davon Leute ich
fahre noch mal in eine andere Richtung
aber alleine in der Zeit genieße ich
einfach mal das gute Wetter
du kannst ja auch schon ein bisschen
weiterbauen ja aber mein Haus ist doch
fertig
ach das bleibt so ja wieso von das ist
jetzt scheiße
sind die Jahre später Leute kommen keine
Fichten ich brauche nur eine 50 ich
brauche nur einen sitzling leute ich
brauch dich denn ich kann mir kein Haus
bauen ohne
fichtenmaterial junge Alter bau dir das
einfach aus Erde so wie die Leute es
damals äh schon gemacht haben als Jesus
noch gelebt hat
weißt du was ich gerade herausgefunden
habe wenn man nur weh drückt springt er
trotzdem automatisch
ey darf ich ein Schwein töten
kommt
ich cheate nicht nein ey würde ich also
wirklich das so spielen wie Du ich würde
immer cheaten ne Luca wollen wir mal 24
Stunden 24 Stunden Minecraft zocken ich
hätte Bock
schreibt sie unten in die Kommentare
[Musik]
wo bist du denn
wo bist du
zur Burg ja es kommt Leute
[Gelächter]
willst du mich verarschen sondern du
hast mich geschlagen ich habe nur
zurückgeschlagen sag mal wenn du Hunger
hast musst du halt Essen ne
im echten Leben würde ich es auch
vergessen dass ich Hunger Alter
du hast ja unten zwei Leisten links hast
du die Herzen und rechts hast du die
hungerkeulen wenn deine hungerkeulen weg
sind musst Du was essen ja okay dann
halt mal was zu essen was du hast
kann man doch Erde Essen
nicht mehr lache wenn ich jemand hast
gerade lachen muss trotzdem ich laufe
jetzt in diese Richtung solange bis ich
eine verdammte Fichte finde
[Musik]
Geld du darfst doch nicht diese Leute
angreifen ja aber die haben mich so
genervt ich dachte das hält kein auf
hey ich kack doch ab das ist wieder nur
eine Insel man
[Musik]
was soll denn der Scheiß Luca ich bin
gerade mega produktiv und bei uns im in
der Stadt was machst du gerade
ich baue einfach den ganzen Rasen ab
hä warum
ist das hier Leute
[Musik]
was ist das kann ich darunter oder ist
das gefährlich ein paar Sekunden später
oh mein Gott
Napoleon
[Musik]
wurdest du getötet
noch lebe ich
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott Leute komme
ich gegen die an doch sieht doch easy
hin oder
oh mein Gott nein nein nein nein nein
noch übermorgen ich will kein ich will
nicht cheaten ich mag das nicht
mal wie das geht weiß ich nicht
Schatzkarte ich habe eine Schatzkarte
gefunden
wofür brauchen wir die das heißt auf
jeden Fall dass irgendwo hier ein Schatz
ist doch weißt du anstatt einfach mal
mir zu helfen weil ich hier gerade
dermaßen aufgeschmissen bin suchst du
nach einem scheiß Holz ich komme mich
hier nicht raus Luca ich bin jetzt ich
bin jetzt getötet worden jetzt ja
ich finde den Schatz nicht da ist kein
Schatz egal ob wir den Schatz findet
oder nicht bei mir geht's gerade um
Leben oder Tod Luca ich schicke dir
jetzt bei Whatsapp die beschissen hoch
ich mir selber mein Turm gebaut habe
damit du einfach mal meine Situation
vielleicht auch erkennst 20 Sekunden
später Sandra aus ja aus ja da bin ich
gerade runtergeflogen habe alles erleben
verloren habe nur noch ein halbes Leben
und kein Essen kannst du mich erstmal
vielleicht retten bevor denn
ich bin in der Höhle alleine ich habe
den Schatz ich habe den Schatz ich habe
ihn
für Sonntag komplett aus nein
ich komme ich bin unterwegs ich stehe
vor deinem Haus wohin jetzt nach links
die Höhle ist offen oben ja jede Höhle
ist oben offen du Idiot
[Musik]
sein
du bist ja echt so ein Trottel ja
verstehst du jetzt mein Problem klaust
du mir noch mein ganzes Holz jetzt
selber abbauen können ja aber ja wie
denn kommen gar nicht so hoch
[Musik]
ja verstehst du jetzt mein pain ja aber
du hättest ja Erde abbauen können Sandra
hier die Erde erzählt mit der Hand
abbauen können das Handy weiß was jetzt
für dich baue falls das normal passiert
was ich bau dir jetzt eine Leiter hoch
ja schön
wir machen erstmal nichts passieren
[Musik]
ich aus jetzt hast du auf jeden Fall
jetzt kann man den nicht mehr so viel
Schaden zufügen guck wenn ich dich jetzt
einmal schlage das passiert fast gar
nichts mehr hier
[Musik]
zweieinhalb Stunden live ich weiß
gestern Abend 5 Stunden da bitte ich
gehe jetzt raus
ich habe jetzt die Verbindung getrennt
beim Spielen
ich
kein Bock ja Leute das war's mit
Minecraft loser für heute ja ich muss
mal schauen wann ich wieder live gehe
aber wenn ihr mir auf Instagram folgt
oder halt wie gesagt hier auf Twitch
folgen
[Musik]